we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point in time
Jordan Peele created this fake video of
President Obama to demonstrate how easy
it is to put words in someone else's
mouth moving forward we need to be more
vigilant with what we trust from the
internet not everyone bought it but the
technology behind such frauds is rapidly
improving even as worries increase about
their potential for harm this is your
Bloomberg quick take on deep fakes deep
fakes or realistic looking fake videos
and audio gained popularity as a means
of adding famous actresses into porn
scenes
despite bans on major websites they
remain easy to make and find they're
named for the deep learning artificial
intelligence algorithms that make them
possible input real audio or video of a
specific person the more the better and
the software tries to recognize patterns
in speech and movement introduce a new
element like someone else's face or
voice and a deep fake is born it's
actually extremely easy to make one of
these things there were just some
suppose you know breakthrough some
academic researchers who work with this
particular kind of machine learning in
the past few weeks which would
drastically reduce the amount of video
you need actually to create programs
like fake app the most popular and
widely available for making deep fakes
need dozens of hours of human assistance
to create a video that looks like this
rather than this
in August researchers at Carnegie Mellon
revealed software that accurately
rendered not just facial features but
changing weather patterns and flowers in
bloom this advance is not yet available
to the public but with increasing
capability comes increasing concern you
know this is kind of fake news on
steroids potentially we do not know of a
case yet where someone has tried to use
this to you perpetrate a fraud or an
information warfare campaign or or for
that matter to really damage someone's
reputation
but it's the danger that everyone is
really afraid of in a world where fakes
are easy to create authenticity also
becomes easier to deny people caught
doing genuinely objectionable things
could claim evidence against them is
bogus fake videos can also be difficult
to detect though researchers around the
world and up the US Department of
Defense have said they're working on
ways to counter them deep fakes do
however have some positive uses take
sera proc a firm that creates digital
voices for people who lose theirs from
disease speech synthesis is the
artificial production of human speech
there are also applications that could
be considered either good or bad like
the many many deep fakes that exist
solely to turn as many movies as
possible into Nicolas Cage movies Oh
you